[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le grand
studio du figaro on est en direct on est
avec vous c'est figaro live et on attend
vos points de vue on les attend
notamment sur la stratégie que doit
poursuivre la france sur la vaccination
contre la copie de 19
peut-elle ou doit-elle s'affranchir de
l'union européenne
on en débat ce soir avec christophe de
vos gonds soir christophe on rappelle
mais doit-on le rappeler vous êtes
historien spécialiste en rhétorique
politique et professeur à sciences po
est également président du conseil
scientifique de la fondapol de la
fondation pour l'innovation politique
est avec vous avec nous ce soir maxime
d'égailler cherche expert à la fondation
jean jaurès également conseiller
régional ps d'île de france avec qui on
va voir un autre débat on lui demandera
tout à l'heure s'il recourt à l'écriture
inclusive à l'état l'offensive en tous
les cas dans les facs un grand dossier à
lire dans les prochaines heures sur le
site et dans les pages du figaro faut-il
une loi pour interdire cette écriture
inclusive dans les services publics pour
faire respecter d'ailleurs un décret qui
avait été signé en décembre 2017 par
edouard philippe c'est en tout cas le
sens d'une proposition de loi da par le
vent ter lr m
et on en débat mais d'abord dont 4% à
peine des français sont vaccinés c'est
le dernier chiffre et ceux qui le
souhaitent doivent encore attendre
attendre et encore attendre et sans
remettre notamment aux promesses de
madame ursula von der leyen
la présidente de la commission
européenne on l'écouté nous devons et
nous allons accélérer la vaccination
dans les semaines et les mois à venir
la livraison des trois vaccins approuvés
va augmenter de nouveaux vaccins seront
disponibles dans un avenir proche
après l'approbation avec les mains les
masses et l' agence européenne du
médicament alors par rapport à ses
promesses de madame von der leyen deux
personnes en france sont assez
sceptiques très naturellement d'abord
l'eurodéputé rassemblement national
jordan bardet
je pense que si la france c'était
tourner directement vers les
laboratoires on s'en serait mieux sorti
parce qu'à chaque fois qu'on confie
quelque chose à l'union européenne c'est
un naufrage système année vous nous
n'avons pas de vaccin parce que de
l'aveu même de la présidente de la
commission européenne qu'il a une qui
l'a indiqué dans les parlementaires
européens qui nous l'indiqué il ya
quelques quelques jours l'union
européenne était totalement défaillant
l'union européenne était totalement
opaque alors sceptiques aussi et bien le
maire républicain de nice christian
estrosi qui a ainsi justifié la mesure
qui a dû être prise pour sa ville et
pour l'ensemble du littoral des
alpes-maritimes
la décision de confiner la colla crise
du coc vie depuis le mois de mars
dernier a démontré à quel point l'union
européenne ne répondait pas aux
véritables enjeux au moment où plus que
jamais nous en avions besoin
mais tant qu'il n'y aura pas une europe
avec des décisions politiques ferme et
forte dans son organisation est sans
doute avec une organisation plus
démocratisé que l'europe elle ne sera
pas suffisamment prête à faire face à ce
type de crise christophe develier 2
accent russe et chinois qui ne sont pas
encore avalisé par la fameuse les mâles
agence européenne du médicament
est ce que la france de passer outre une
confié son examen à son agence du
médicament et puis 6,6 et avalisé six et
validé y recourir paul et moi j'ai pas
de vous savez je suis assez pragmatique
donc j'ai pas de religion là dessus il
faudrait pas qu'on remplace une
dépendance européenne qui met quand même
je dirais plus chère et plus qui me
paraît quand même moins dangereuse par
une dépendance russe ou et a fortiori
chinoise on a déjà si j'ose dire une
dépendance aux virus ou est ce que je
veux dire qui nous vient de chine et il
faudrait éviter surtout qu'à des sens
comment les russes et les chinois
utilisent leur la somme on sait plus si
on dirait du soft du hard power à la
matière un bac à bac 5 est ce que c'est
c'est cdu du power troisième génération
c'est du smart power on va dire et cette
je crois qu'il faut faire attention
je dirais oui évidemment qu'il faut être
pragmatique si ça peut
apporter un complément un complément
bien une stratégie qui doit quand même
resté à l'époque où nous parle que
d'indépendance nationale de retour de la
souveraineté qu'elles soient nationales
ou européennes d'autonomie de
relocalisation je trouverais un peu
risqué de remettre notre campagne de
vaccination dans les mains de poutine de
xi jinping
maxime d'égailler est-ce que c'était pas
un luxe de vouloir faire l'europe de la
santé de profiter entre guillemets du
duc au vide et du de vaccinés la
vaccination des problèmes de
vaccinations pour faire l'europe de la
santé alors que l'urgence était plutôt
d'avoir vite des doses comme l'ont
démontré à avant les problèmes sur les
masques et sur les tests ben vous l'avez
dit si on prend le sujet sur la qui sont
des vaccins
je ne trouve pas que l'europe soit plus
défaillante que la france et à la
question posée tout à l'heure le député
front national en disant qu'il faisait
pas confiance en europe parce que chaque
fois que l'europe touché quelque chose
ça se passait mal moi j'ai plutôt qu'on
puisse confiance en l'europe pour gérer
les vaccins que dans la gouvernance
makrout plus début de la crise parce que
les problèmes qu'on a eus à le test les
aveux de lenteur de la part de la coop
et migros pm particulier après les aveux
de menteur il n'y a pas eu d'abus de
lenteur il ya eu effectivement et ça
c'est des choses qui doivent être
améliorés peut-être un défaut d'ailleurs
d'investissement le thème était de
savoir s'il fallait s'affranchir de
l'union européenne sur les vaccins moi
j'ai tendance à penser que l'on aurait
dû plus s'investir sur ce sujet là et on
voit arriver effectivement investir ou
plus investir il pleut les deux mon
général puisse avait plus un vrai
investir financièrement et d'ailleurs
ils le font plus s'investir aussi parce
qu'on voit que les contrats ont pas
toujours été bien négociés et on voit
que d'une certaine manière l'europe
comme d'habitude est un géant qui
s'ignore et qu' elle n'a pas peut-être
mener leur apporte de fortes incertaine
d'ailleurs mais le rapport de force qui
devait être attendu de la part de ces
puissances à après si on refait le film
parce que certainement c'est des
technocrates parce qu'il ya aussi des
déçus des des enjeux contradictoires je
voyais le spiegel il ya quelques mois
qu'il ya les quotidiens exactement un
quotidien allemand qui expliquait que en
tout cas il met une hypothèse qui était
démentie depuis par le gouvernement
français mais qui accusait le
gouvernement français d'avoir dans ces
négociations là peut-être favorisé un
peu trop sanofi au détriment des autres
vaccins candidats à l'époque ce qui
aurait expliqué le fait qu'ils aient pas
assez de doses
notamment du vaccin de pfizer c'est ce
quotidien quand même reconnu qu'il a
mentionné on voit bien que l'isr qui a
créé un vaccin avec des attaques
allemandes exactement mais mais voyez
bien que là dessus évidemment il ya des
interrogations
il ya déjà des réactions il ya des
intérêts nationaux qui en rentrent en
ligne de compte mais alors si vous
prenez ce raisonnement là si la france
était parti tout seul d'abord est-ce que
la france aurait eu la capacité de
négocier ces vaccins alors je sais qu'on
est une grande puissance et qu'on rêve
toujours de l'être mais je pense que
l'europe était certainement plus
puissante que la france tout seul pour
pouvoir négocier avec ces laboratoires
et la deuxième chose c'est que à ce
moment là certains auraient certes et on
aurait pu comprendre aurait peut-être
privilégiées sanofi dans ces vaccins
candidats et on voit le résultat
ça nous fait aujourd'hui incapable de
sortir un vaccin dans les temps donc moi
je trouve que l'europe c'est évident que
c'est le bon cadre pour pouvoir gérer
cette crise la question qui nous est
posée c'est comment on s'investit plus
encore et face aujourd'hui aux problèmes
opérationnels qui sont posées notamment
en termes de production même du vaccin
moi j'aimerais qu'ils ne répondraient
européenne et que ça ne soit pas et que
le rapport de force ce soir est
clairement posée avec des laboratoires
je suis très largement très largement
d'accord je crois qu'en plus c'est ya
toujours cette espèce de sophismes qui
consiste à reprocher à leurs proches à
l'europe tous tout et son contraire
c'est à dire notamment le front national
lors banon le rassemblement national qui
reproche à l'europe de n'être pas
efficace et qui lui interdit de l'être
puisque on dit à l'europe
vous n'avez pas de polypes de politique
de santé mais il n'a lui pas question
vous en ayez une
est ce que vous voyez l'injonction
contradictoires puisqu'on refuse la
communautarisation de la politique de
santé qui reste comme vous avez une
prérogative nationale
ce qu'on oublie toujours donc j'ai
tendance à dire que on peut pas
reprocher à l'europe de ne pas faire
assez de faire trop en même temps est ce
que je veux dire
deuxièmement il est absolument certain
et là je tout à fait dans votre sens qu'
il faut quand même pas raconter
d'histoires dans un rapport de force où
vous êtes
je suis désolé de le dire on nous dit
toujours la 5e ou l'assistance de
sixième puissance du monde non nous ne
sommes pas la cinquième ou la sixième
puissance du monde
économiquement nous sommes là 8
mais quand même quand même un jour le 10
rebonds nous sommes la huitième
puissance du monde
nous avons des intérêts nous savons que
dans la gestion de la crise des intérêts
corporatistes industriels etc
technocratique ont pu jouer peser sur la
décision publique
moi je sais pas s'il de faire de
l'histoire au conditionnel passé mais je
pense je vais même plus loin que vous je
pense qu'on aurait eu un gros problème
d'approvisionnement en vaccin parce
qu'on aurait attendu sanofi ou qu'on
aurait laissé on aurait acheté allez
disons 3 millions de doses de pfizer et
on aurait des crs pour et on serait gros
jean comme devant
voilà continuer je sors à nourrir les
vaches regardent et quand même courbe
qui est publié par le site a horreur des
qui publie en temps réel à peu près le
le taux de vaccination dans le monde ce
qui est très intéressant alors
effectivement à la voilà un petit peu
lointaine mais ce qu'on voit c'est que
l'europe
finalement le taux
de vaccination dans européenne il est
tout en bas il est aux alentours de 6%
alors que même la france on est en
dessous de ce taux là et on est loin
derrière israël les émirats arabes unis
la grande bretagne
donc la question encore une fois est-ce
que je veux bien vous entendre que 1,27
on est plus fort que tout seul mais on
voit bien que il des dations qui sont
seules ont des taux de vaccinations qui
sans cela je me permettrait d'être en
désaccord avec vous c'est à dire que
l'acccident ronces et on leur pose c'est
pas je vous pose la question qui
explique ce qui explique aujourd'hui
c'est différent taux de vaccination
n'est pas on va dire le véhicule qui le
portent c'est à dire l'europe où la
france ce sont les conditions dans
laquelle on accepte ces vaccinations là
donc il faut pas tout confondre
et effectivement nous avons une
convergence de vues aujourd'hui enfin
vieux en plus la façon dont est gérée la
crise par
l'état français est objectivement moi je
n'aurais jamais parié et sur le fait
qu'on s'en sorte mieux sur la question
des vaccins cancer on s'en est sorti sur
la question des tests ou des masses mais
bref c'est un technocrate français
en tout cas ils ont l'air un peu plus
efficace mais au-delà de ça non mais
qu'est ce qu'on est en train de sublimer
la france par rapport à l'europe sur ce
sujet je pense que c'est une grave
erreur
pour revenir aux propos parce que ce que
vous que ce que je veux indiquer c'est
que les pays qui ont aujourd'hui des
taux de vaccination plus important non
pas rogner sur des éléments d'ailleurs
qui se poserait à l'europe comme la
france l'israël c'est parce que
notamment ils ont demandé à être on va
dire les premiers candidats à la
vaccination et on sait qu'il y avait
notamment des sujets de partage de
données sur lequel elles ont été très
allants avec le laboratoire pfizer et
sur lequel on peut imaginer que l'europe
comme la france aurait peut-être était
plus réservé pour des questions de
protection des données
surtout deux noms mais l'europe comme la
france bah oui donc vous imaginez que si
c'était la france voir partir et
deuxièmement sur les autres protection
des rames quelque chose d'assez
communément partagée en europe
exactement mais on met mais on est quand
je ne vois pas je n'aurai moi pas
forcément été favorable à ce que leurs
proches sur ça et je n'ose imaginer que
la france auraient rogné par rogné par
elle-même sur les autres sur les autres
sur les autres territoires concernés
voyez bien qu'il ya des sujets qui sont
posées notamment en termes de candidats
bac 5 qui et quels sont ceux qui ont été
retenus ou en termes de doses je vous
rappelle que pour la grande bretagne le
choix qui a été fait ça a été
et bien d'allonger le délai de
vaccination entre deux doses qui n'a pas
été fait pour des questions on va dire
scientifique et d'évaluation des risques
donc ce sont ces sujets là aujourd'hui
qui explique ces différences de courbes
et non pas le fait que ce soit l'europe
à l'europe alors je vous propose
de partager avec vous ce que disent les
commentaires des internautes d'y réagir
pourquoi la france au lieu d'en acheter
ne se mettra pas à fabriquer ce vaccin à
elle même c'est tout le problème
justement qu'on a rencontrés avec sanofi
qui n'avait plus les savoir faire non
plus pour le pour le faire l'europe en
ce moment c'est un pour tous et chacun
pour soi dix-sept autres internautes
alors pas encore chacun joue quand même
entre le cas de tous ceux qui ont joué
là en tout cas le le jeu de la
vaccination à l'intérieur de l'union
européenne
il ya encore une solidarité qui reste on
est d'accord sur ça oui oui un petit peu
comme un peu comme dans brick site quoi
c'est à dire face à face à l'angleterre
c'est à dire face au virus il ya encore
une solidarité
l'achat groupé l'union européenne permet
de bénéficier d'un rabais commercial
nous
dit gilles ça c'est un argument plutôt
faible quand même c'est quasiment fait
l'union européenne n'est jamais efficace
pourquoi le serait telle dans ce domaine
alors effectivement on m'avait pas
expliquer en quoi l'union européenne
avait été efficace dans ce domaine c'est
bien parce qu'elle avait négociés à
l'appui négocier des doses importantes
alors le au rabais comme dit gilles
offre au rabais mais vont de la mer
durables et la question aujourd'hui
c'était pas seulement le prix c'était
d'abord un accès direct
or aujourd'hui c'est 2 milliards de deux
entre deux et trois milliards de doses
qui ont été commandés alors avec auprès
de six laboratoire parce que l'ensemble
des vaccins n'ont pas abouti on a parlé
de sanofi il ya un instant et il est
évident que quand je pense à n'importe
qui qui travaillent dans le commerce
connaît bien le sujet si vous arrivez et
que vous indiquez que vous êtes vous
pouvez prendre un grand volume de doses
vous serez toujours prioritaire face à
celui qui pourra prendre à faible dose
de un faible nombre de doses est
d'ailleurs le sujet posé aujourd'hui on
a vu tout à l'heure votre vote graphique
ce sont les pays qui sont les pays
isolés et qui ne sont pas des grandes
puissances et qui aujourd'hui n'ont pas
d'accès aux vaccins donc si on parce
qu'elles n'ont pas la capacité de
pouvoir négocier
voilà pourquoi l'europe à mon sens a
fait son job c'est à dire qu'elle a pas
elle fait parler d'une seule voix et on
a pris des commandes convient aussi je
regarde mon graphique je comprends pas
trop votre résonance si je regarde le
graphique justement je vois que des
petits pays ont réussi à avoir un retour
de vie sur des petits pays en avant en
l'occurrence vous verrez le japon n'a
pas encore commencé sa campagne de
vaccination et c'est pas un petit pays
et en l'occurrence entre quand on parle
de pitchfork beaucoup de respect pour
israël qui est exact mais qui est pas un
grand pays mais israël a la taille ou
par un traitement mais il a marre marre
marre l'histoire et la culture et le
dynamisme économique et industriel
traitement et surtout comme je le dis
parce que israël avait proposé d'être le
pays allait lancer la vaccination qui ce
qui intéressait pas leaders pour pouvoir
avoir des données qui lui permettent
d'avoir un retour immédiat sur le succès
de
de son traitement donc c'est pour ça que
je dis ce sont des conditions
spécifiques de négociations ça qu'on
était un sujet quand même il faut être
un peu pragmatique quand vous vous
interrogez les uns et les autres
tout le monde est ravi que israël donne
ses abonnés à pfizer parce que ça
servira tout le monde puisque grâce à ça
préserve à aller beaucoup plus vite dans
l'analyse des effets secondaires dans la
nécessité d'un d'une nouvelle version en
fonction des variants ils sont en train
de travailler à vitesse accélérée et
peut-être que là cet accord a peut-être
été aussi pour le bien de l'europe vous
verrez et que je crois qu'il ya des faux
procès d'autre part je pense qu'on peut
dire de façon générale alors que
l'europe que l'on accuse n'est quand
même que la somme de ses parties de
façon générale quand vous regardez les
opinions politiques et surtout l'opinion
des dirigeants à commencer par les
nôtres rappelez vous quand même c'est
pas si longtemps il y avait un grand
scepticisme sur les vaccins c'est à dire
rappelez vous quand même que le
président français avait dit vous rêvez
y aura pas de vaccins avant souvenez
vous l'été 2021
bon il y avait un grand scepticisme sur
les vaccins il y avait une grande
réticence dans la grave blessure dont la
nature vaccinale de ce conte de ce qu'on
a trouvé sûr que je pars en trouver un
débat de spécialistes mais commence où
les débats ont été ont changé et parce
que la vaccination a marché combien de
gens qui protestent aujourd'hui contre
la lenteur de l'union européenne
notamment rassemblement national était
plutôt anti vaccin s'il me semble départ
est ce que je me trompe pas au départ
être extrêmement prudent est ce qu'il ya
un certain nombre d'anti vaccin qui
votera sans mentionner un petit peu
différent non mais les positions
officielles de marine le pen je vous
savez que je n'attaque pas gratuitement
mais les positions de marine le pen dans
cette affaire rappelez-vous ce qu'elle
disait sur le vaccin au début soyons
prudents aujourd'hui elle dit citant
femme assez vite ce qui est vrai c'est
qu'un certain nombre de
d'eurodéputés ou bien de eurosceptiques
comme leur assemblée nationale où la
france un smith ont critiqué les
conditions dans lesquelles étaient
négociés les vaccins à l'arrivée des
vagues ça et surtout l'opacité rica il y
avait quand même aux violences de la
part du parti d'extrême droite mais on
va dire une réserve parce que c'était
son tout ce qui est nouveau fait peur il
y avait mais en l'occurrence il y avait
une réserve il y avait une réserve assez
forte sur sur une stratégie vaccinale
vous avez raison d'ailleurs aujourd'hui
d'une certaine manière les mêmes nous
explique que c'est particulièrement mais
franchement dans beaucoup de pays
d'europe 1
soit on avait peur soit on n'y croyait
pas je le connais bien les pays bas par
exemple ils n'ont pas du tout joué la
vaccination est d'ailleurs ils sont pour
bien meilleure que nous reconnaît qu'il
ya un certain nombre de gens qui ont
critiqué notamment c'est encore une fois
les conditions aux négociations de
l'union européenne sur l'opacité des
conditions de l'opacité des négociations
accusant même une partie de la
commission européenne plus ou moins sous
la pression des lobbies
oui ce qui évidemment ne venez pas dans
les pays des labos des labos des labos
des labos pharmaceutiques et mais c'est
quelque chose qui était partagé par le
rassemblement national la france
insoumise en france et par un certain
nombre de libéraux néerlandais 2
et d'eurosceptiques de tout poil ce pays
a moins de besoins de vaccins que de
liberté voilà voiliers du différentes
dont celles fondamental de pouvoir aller
et venir
l'allemagne n'est-elle pas en discussion
avec la russie sur le sujet nous demande
nicole les chardons bleus nous dit de
toute façon on allait warum nicht
d'autres façons en attend un vaccin
français en quoi serait-il légitime de
la part de l'union européenne de se
préoccuper des systèmes de santé
nationaux nous dit demande tu entends
justement ça se faisait au pays mais
entendre le point de vue de maxime sur
cette question et mais un mot pour qu'on
puisse aller alors que je prendrais puis
sur cette question mais évoquer quelque
chose d'autre qui est qu'en réalité le
lac estion vaccinale aller ce qui pose
problème dans le vaccin aujourd'hui
c'est surtout la mise en oeuvre
opérationnelle et on l'a vu nous avec
tout ce qui s'est passé
les publics cibles qu'ils n'étaient pas
les bons des délais annoncés qui n'ont
pas fonctionné parce que là où vous avez
raison c'est que quand on regarde et
qu'on prend un peu de recul
le fait qu'il y ait déjà autant de
vaccins avec une pandémie qui arrivent
il ya si peu de temps est déjà un
exploit en soi
donc le problème ça a été les toutous
les rater ce n'est pas en deux valeurs
absolues gers et déjà on va dire quelque
chose d'assez incroyable qu'on ait
réussi à vacciner autant de personnes le
problème c'est qu'on a des gouvernements
et là c'est pas l'europe qui ont
qui est qui n'ont pas été bons sur les
stratégies vaccinales qui d'ailleurs on
auprès des différentes la fois la
stratégie vaccinale qui sont nationale 1
c'est à dire faut bien rappeler parce
que tout le monde ne le sait pas c'est à
dire qu'ils vaccinent et européens mais
la stratégie n'a été qu'un pool d'achat
et les italiens par exemple ont décidé
eux d'abord de en priorité de vacciner
le personnel se manière des soignants
absolue ce qui était d'ailleurs plus
facile pour plein de raisons semaine où
les difficultés qu'on a eue sur les
ehpad parce qu'ils avaient fait ce choix
là parce qu'il considérait que c'était
ce qui était en première en première
ligne qui devaient être vaccinés en
premier que faute de l'europe
ça c'est une fois que je le responsable
17h20 sur figueruelas les italiens mais
jamais ils sont jamais diot va personne
ne le pense ici en tous les cas on aime
trop l'italie pour pouvoir le penser et
nos chercheurs sont partis à l'étranger
ou de son mieux considérés et mieux
payés nous dit roland je remarque que le
royaume-uni se portent bien mieux que
nous le dit kris kross s'il n'y a pas de
politique de santé européennes pourquoi
attend donc l'union européenne pour
commander des vaccins nous demande
nicole donc la christ vous a répondu je
pense nicole en disant que le numéro des
centrales d'achat a servi deux centrales
d'achat on a refusé le vaccin ce pique
nique pour des raisons idéologiques ce
qui est idiot estime le même puisque
ross et david sur youtube qui nous
parlait des autorités sanitaires mais
j'ai perdu justement le message il va
revenir je le donne ne vous inquiétez
pas de vide
les autorités sanitaires européennes aux
français ce sont les mêmes personnes je
ne vois pas la différence
on doit avoir un maximum de garanties
sur les vaccins demande patrick et
leonidas dans le domaine des achats
plus on est gros mieux c'est c'était le
point de vue de maxime d'égailler
également et de christophe de vote
je vous propose d'abord de regarder la
réponse à la question qu'on peut poser
sur twitter la france doit être se
procurer des vaccins contre la copie de
10,9 sans passer par l'union européenne
bah je suis désolé messieurs mais vous
n'êtes pas convaincu en tout cas les les
gens qui se pratique se sont exprimés
sur twitter vous n'avez pas posé la
question je posais gens d'être ne vous
avait pas posé la question à nous ah oui
la france doit-elle ce projet avec
vaccin contre la colombie dix neuf ans
passés par l'union européenne
je présume de la réponse ah non moi je
suis je pense qu'à titre et je lis un
peu pour le vaccin russe à titre on
dirait subsidiaire comme on dit moi je
suis tout à fait pour ce qu'ont fait les
allemands d acheter s'ils manquent si un
problème un fournisseur un vaccin qui
marche moins bien je suis tout à fait
pour qu'on complète
je suis favorable à ce qu'on passe par
l'union européenne alors on n'est pas
d'accord on aurait dû commencer par là
on va soit un point de désaccord
maxime est ce que vous écrivez en
écriture inclusif le oui ça m'arrive et
vous christophe à je sais pas faire moi
j'ai déjà du mal à écrire en français
sans fautes
alors est-ce qu'il faut une loi pour
justement interdire limité en tout cas l
usage de l'écriture inclusive dans
l'administration
c'est le voeu d'un député lrm un élu de
l'indre qui s'appelle françois jolivet
alors il a reçu on va lier en entendre
une parlementaire elle soutient donc
d'autres parlementaires à l'intérieur de
son mouvement également dans les partis
alliés également chez les républicains
va y revenir dans un instant mais ça
suffit d' une polémique au sein d
du groupe de la république en marche et
notamment une parlementaire drm qui a
accusé françois jolivet d'être un homme
attaché à ses privilèges ses privilèges
de dom
ce n'est pas en tout cas l'avis donc
d'une des signataires la députée lr
annie genevard on le goûte aujourd'hui
il ya une instance il n'y a pas de norme
n'y a pas de règle qui protège la langue
chacun peut faire de la langue ce qu'il
veut et ça ce n'est pas possible on voit
bien qu'il ya là une dérive d'une
initiative qui était parti de la volonté
de militants de donner plus de
visibilité ou féminin dans la langue
française c'est évidemment l'opinion de
ceux qui la promeuvent et qui considère
qu'en donnant plus de visibilité au
fémina dans la langue on en donnera
davantage dans la vie ce que je ne crois
pas alors christophe vous pensez non
j'ai compris que vous n'écrivez pas un
écriture inclusive mais est ce que vous
pensez comme parlementaire et les roms
qui préside françois jolivet ou comme
annie genevard oui moi je pense que ça
l'est tout dépend des marchés un peu un
peu universitaire tout dépend de ce
qu'on attendait avec très répandu des
sciences po il attendait dans les
facultés en tweed l écriture de robert
exactement l'écriture inclusive moi j'ai
un peu travaillé pour cette émission est
aussi pour d'autres cieux pour d'autres
occasions et franchement il ya autant
c'est d'écriture inclusive elle est très
diverse 1 c'est à dire ça va de la
féminisation des noms et des fonctions
jusqu'à les points
vous savez le point médian en passant
par des yens pour dire ils et elles
s'appellent wyss en disant très
extensible ça peut aller jusqu'à vous
savez hauteur au triste mais aussi aux
touristes pour ne pas indisposer des
transgenres donc qu est ce qu on appelle
l écriture inclusive et déjà jean
tendance à dire qu'une orthographe qui
se présente de façon aussi instable dans
un pays où déjà la maîtrise de
l'orthographe
vous prenez un exemple est
catastrophique écoutez les choses telles
qu'elles sont et notamment à
l'université
vous avez donc introduire une complexité
supplémentaire si on proche de la
définition
je dirais point médian enfin global qui
va comme toujours défavorisés les plus
défavorisés mais ça on sait que c'est le
prenez position militante
vous savez très bien c'est un peu comme
le prennent le point de vue des cantines
à lyon nous avons dû retirer à la maison
donc pas la peine de tourner à la
cantine tandis que là c'est pareil
l'orthographe nous on sait la faire tant
pis pour les plus pauvres
ils savent déjà pas écrire peu importe
pour eux donc il ya un côté ce que
l'appel l'enfer des plus défavorisés est
pavé de bonnes intentions des bobos mais
encore une fois je parle de l'écriture
inclusive militante pour j'insiste
beaucoup là-dessus parce que pour la
féminisation de la langue
j'aurai une position beaucoup plus au
contraire ouverte avancé à condition de
bien s'entendre sur les choses et en
posant des questions une question quand
même été très importante c'est le
diagnostic est ce qu'une langue genre et
est une comme on dit est une langue qui
invisibilité les femmes moi j'ai un
problème du point de vue scientifique
est ce qu'une langue ou le neutre
l'emportent naville israël pas davantage
les femmes prenez l'exemple de l'anglais
est ce qu'on va dire que la société
britannique ou américaine - patriarcale
que la france parce que af french in the
friend d'accord on n'a pas une amie on a
un ami toujours ok donc l'anglais
beaucoup plus neutre que le français
est ce que on va dire dans ces cas là
que le français est un visibilis plus
les femmes on peut même tenir l'opinion
contraire que dans une langue genre et
comme les langues latines
la femme est plus visible puisqu'on voit
on à la désignation elle est belle et
non pas à l'ebbo en anglais on dirait
elle est beau on est d'accord
bon donc on peut tout à fait à discuter
de la tenue de cette base qui me paraît
très largement contestable alors en tant
qu'historien je voudrais pas c'est d'en
parler quand on crée de riz siens mais
en tant qu'historien comme toujours
comme on parle beaucoup du sujet d'islam
au gauchissement des sujets de ces
sujets là attendez ce sont très souvent
quand on est à l'université je peux vous
dire il y à des intersections comme ils
disent eux-mêmes entre les défenseurs de
la culture inclusive et tous les autres
je dis bien encore une fois des
militants à ceux qui sont pourriels ceux
qui sont pour l'autoriser et sait donc
comment dire c'est à chaque fois pareil
vous est pris entre le marteau du
progressisme et l'enclume du
conservatisme
moi je suis encore une fois tout à fait
ouverts sur ces questions de
féminisation mais je dis qu'il ya
énormément de contresens
j'ai lu par exemple comme argument en
faveur de l'écriture inclusive que les
droits de l'homme ont été faites pour
exclure les femmes textos ont été faites
pour exclure des femmes je suis désolé
je suis historien j'ai dû tout ou les
cahiers de préparation des droits de
l'homme ce n'est trouvable nulle part
nulle part payet il faut qu'il était un
ticket quand même que vous avez que les
femmes étaient représentés par le chef
de famille non je parle de la
déclaration des dommages ou vol des
travaux préparatoires et bien il n'est
jamais il est jamais dit que les
quelques heures le luth et d'ex hurler
et d'ailleurs vous savez que sur la
déclaration des droits de l'homme
je parle pas de celle de la révolution
française tous les pays du monde ont mis
le droit humain sauf la france
considérant qu'il fallait justement
faire un parallèle avec les droits de
l'homme issu de la révolution française
donc si vous voulez moi ce que je trouve
intéressant à bord je remarque vous avez
des arguments affûtés mais qui sont si
vous me permettez assez symptomatique
aussi du débat sous jacent en réalité de
cette question d'écriture inclusive
c'est à dire alors de vous à moi je suis
pas certain que cette proposition de loi
je pense que peut-être d'autres sujets
aujourd'hui plus important avait pas la
même sujet d'autant parle j'entends et
je me permettait de dire que
deuxièmement c'est un sujet qui revient
souvent sans régler problème puisque
j'avais vu qu'il y avait une proposition
de loi portée par le front national en
juillet dernier qui était déjà sur le
même le même débat est derrière en
réalité 7,7
cette volonté d'interdire puisque c'est
le sujet l'écriture inclusive c'est une
volonté de considérer que la langue ne
doit pas bouger et c'est là où moi j'ai
un vrai problème c'est à dire que la
langue aujourd'hui
et claude duneton qui avait écrit
d'ailleurs une tribune dans le figaro
avant avant de disparaître et qui peut
pas être taxé d'être sûr aussi
progressiste que je ne le suis expliqué
très bien que le but d'une langue c'est
d'être vivante et qu'on ne peut pas
aujourd'hui considérer qu'il faut rien
changer parce que vous l'avez dit
vous-même vous mettez dans le même sac
la question de l'orthographe
la question de l'évolution de sa
féminisation or on est dans un jeu
aujourd'hui moi je ne mets pas dans la m
on voit aujourd'hui on est dans un pays
aujourd'hui ou notamment avec l'académie
faux avec l'académie française me
faisais une distance par rapport à la
distinction que faisait christophe qui
est de dire ok pour la féminisation des
noms puisque au nom de l'évolution de la
langue mais par contre sur le plan de ce
que disait christophe c'est à dire que
l'écriture inclusive introduire un
niveau de complexité supplémentaire qui
est justement au lieu d'inclure qui
exclut moi c'est pas un peu objective
même à mon sens ces essais la royal
françois jolivet qui dit l'écrit
lékritir inclusive exclut les gens qui
sont en situation de handicap
des experts de la dyslexie dyspraxie et
dysphasie sont préoccupés et alerte sur
des difficultés supplémentaires
engendrés par cette forme d kalck alors
moi je veux bien entendre ses arguments
lors d'abord au passage d'autres des
associations de personnes en situation
de handicap explique avec raison que le
prenez pas l'écriture inclusive à imite
le problème c'est les logiciels
puisqu'il ya aussi j'ai bien compris et
difficultés notamment pour les aveugles
de pouvoir intégrer le point médian ça
ça se règle par un logiciel donc il ya
mon avis il faut pouvoir distinguer géré
le promener mais c'est le la technologie
que vous avez utilisé pour pouvoir
permettre à des aveugles de pouvoir lire
un texte ce n'est pas la façon dont vous
allez écrire au passage qu'elle ait
excuse a juste au passage foyer
passerelle est la raison pour laquelle
vous êtes favorable héritage je suis
pour l'écriture égalitaire réussi et qui
entre les hommes et les femmes entre
elles et d'une certaine manière pour
pour casser ce qui est ce qui était
d'ailleurs dans les travaux
préparatoires du premier dictionnaire de
l'académie française donc ça date qui
était de considérer que l'orthographe
que d'une certaine manière le l'écriture
était le moyen de distinguer les gens
lettrés des ignorants ou des simples
femmes et il ya un sujet ci ont alors
beaucoup de la sas est un des bateaux
des salons littéraires du 17e et oui
mais non mais c'est un débat très
intéressant c'est effectivement est ce
que la langue aujourd'hui doit être un
facteur de distinction est et ce qu'elle
doit elle doit aussi être un élément pas
le seul mais un élément qui aussi
l'expression des évolutions d'une
société et d'ailleurs je vous rappelle
que si à un moment donné on a créé
l'académie française c'est aussi pour
pouvoir uniformiser le français à
l'époque face aux langues régionales
donc c'était un relais l'académie
française a joué ce rôle là aujourd'hui
la question qui doit être posée c'est
d'être aussi on va dire en phase avec ce
que la société française est aujourd'hui
je remarque que les arguments qu'on
avance que qui ont été avancées à un
instant que vous avez repris enfin que
vous avez relaté qui était de dire par
exemple que ça posait un problème de
difficultés ah ok mais alors vous savez
que pour le son est ce en langue
française il peut être écrit de 22 façon
différente
donc on peut aussi travailler à ce
moment là sur une sur une approche plus
accessible du langage
sauf que si on est honnête entre nous on
sait très bien que de ceux qui
aujourd'hui s'opposent à l'évolution de
la langue et à l'écriture inclusive sont
les mêmes qui vont s'opposer à toute
réforme de l'orthographe pourquoi
parceque il met aujourd'hui le
l'écriture sur un piédestal mais
personne n'est là pour le personne ne
défend sa non mais moi je dis
dans les deux cas est ce que est ce que
justement d'un autre côté il n'y a pas
un autre paradoxe
maxime desgagnés c'est que ceux qui sont
parfois pour la simplification de
l'orthographe sont favorables à
l'écriture en cuisine qui ne vise pas la
saq utilisation leur toit et moi moi
j'ai dit que j'étais pour gt pour
l'écriture égalitaire il ya des piliers
de l'écriture à la guitare notamment
c'est effectivement de ne pas faire
passer la femme derrière l'homme donc
l'écriture inclusive aujourd'hui c'est
une modalité pour pouvoir y arriver mais
le problème que ne règle pas cette
proposition de loi c'est que là vous
avez raison c'est qu'il faudrait qu'on
ait des normes qu'on se mette d'accord
qu'on ait un débat sur aujourd'hui le
langage
sauf qu'aujourd'hui vous avez quoi vous
avez les décisions du haut-conseil
décision du concept de l'autorité de
l'égalité pardon vous avez effectivement
cette directive de loire philippe depuis
2010 est qui d'ailleurs mené l'étude a
créé un cas qui n'est qu'une circulaire
je suis je suis d'accord mais qui est a
priori qu'à nice en sera t il de la
france et l'irak à ce qu'on raconte
l'académie française
oui pas force de loi qui n'est pas force
de loi mais qui par ailleurs est force
beaucoup de mes faire confiance plus ça
c'est un autre sujet et donc cueillir
par la cagne france va coûter moi j'ai
j'ai du mal avec ces institutions qui
bloque tout mais met donc si vous voulez
qu'il ya un vrai débat sur aujourd'hui
la façon dont normes le langage est donc
fait évoluer ça ça serait intéressant
oui il ya une grande différence entre
l'évolution vivant de la langue à
laquelle on est tous d'accord à bhl et
là c'est pas pareil du tout c'est une
imposition militante avec l'espagne la
position personne là bas
ah bon mais si les gens veulent
interdire à la pause vous plaisantez
d'en bas c'est pas la joie non non non
non c'est quelque chose je vous rappelle
qu'il ya donc quelque chose qui n'est
qu' étant même proscrit dans le cadre
administrative par le premier ministre
et qui est quand même en applications
courantes dans l'administration moi ça
me pose un petit problème de
républicains qui devraient d'ailleurs
vous touchez en tant qu' en tant que
républicain convaincu
ça me gêne toujours quand la loi n'est
pas respectée par l'administration
puisque le savez c'est quand même un
problème vraiment vous voulez vous même
la dépasser pour ça qu'ils font une ppl
demain si cette ppl elle passe ça sera
interdite à temps il ya une excusez-moi
fois vous le pression je peux vous le
dire social allait d'ailleurs des
universités c'est un peu on va parler
d'islam au gauchisme je compare il ya
une pression et 70 ans et connaît
toujours en verve ce jour là charge de
la victimisation
c'est quand même les gens qui militent
en aveugle imposer des mesures qui font
pression sur les excuser moi est ce que
quand vous avez l'académie française qui
pendant des décennies ont dépêché en
nanomètres et a effacé le terme motrices
ou ambassadrice rit parce qu'il
considère aller à l'époque que ça devait
être effacés si vous laissiez avec
l'ambassadrice était la femme de
l'ambassadeur puri officiellement
justement non historiquement
l'ambassadrice ça pouvait être un
ambassadeur même sait comment il est
effectivement il ya une évolution qui a
été dictée notamment comme vous l'avez
dit mais on va dire par le magistère
moral de l'académie française qui a
considéré qu'il fallait que maintenant
c'est ça ne pouvait être que l'épousé de
l'ambassadeur ça c'est pas qu'il a
décidé c'est l'académie française tout
seul
heureusement qu'il ya eu des forces
sociales pour faire évoluer ce débat-là
et et comme je me cache derrière duneton
mais comme vous avez aujourd'hui et
c'est heureux et bien une affirmation
plus forte
de la place des femmes dans la société
je considère que la langue elle doit
obtenir je crois que tu vois là repose
très souvent sur des erreurs mais
linguistique majeur je prends un exemple
sortons un peu du français en allemand
ce sera le dernier oui en allemand la
marque du neutre au pluriel où la marque
du masculin au pluriel c'est dit et il
c'est à dire les marques du féminin est
ce que quelqu'un va se dire on a qu'en
allemand il ya un privilège du féminin
moi je vous dis oh non mais
l'argumentation est tout simplement
eh bien vous avez aujourd'hui il est
vrai par contre mon repos pardon pour
intervenir et me frappe en tous les cas
c'est que par exemple en allemand on n'a
pas une chose qu'on en français on n'a
pas une chose qui en allemand la jeune
fille maintenant c'est d'une autre mais
alors que c'est est-ce que c'est pas
violent c'était la question du mal à
viser les nationaux injustement leur
usage du français de les reconnaît à la
jeune fille sa féminité
non mais je suis ou les rongeurs je veux
bien que maintenant on s'occupe de
l'allemagne l'europe n'était pas
forcément le seul raisonnement sur le
raisonnement aujourd'hui vous savez que
si vous prenez 1 1
un générique un générique plutôt
masculin il ya des études qui sont ici
là dessus typiquement hommes
ça va forcément de vous donner une
représentation mentale à 23 % pour les
femmes alors que si vous prenez si vous
prenez un générique kaki 1 épicène comme
humain bah vous aurez 43% alors ce que
je dis c'est que je ne dis pas qu'on
répète également épicène ça signifie que
ce sont des mots qui peuvent être aussi
bien employé au féminin comme ça j'en
ris et dominique où vous êtes un prénom
et puis c'est que je souhaite indiquer
par là c'est que je voulais dit tout à
l'heure ça me
il y aurait un vrai débat à avoir sur
aujourd'hui l'évolution de la langue ça
serait un beau débat parlementaire et un
beau débat intellectuel
aujourd'hui je note juste qu'une fois de
plus on prend ce sujet là pour
considérer qu'il y aurait des choses qui
ne devraient pas évoluer parce que on
viendrait touche à l'identité de la
france parce que c'est ça derrière et ça
s'est arrêté avec un b salarié bordelais
homme de paille c'est à dire que vous
préparez à vincent rey à moi des
allemands n'avons pas du tout amer mais
c'est parce que autour de vous je me
permet d'essayer d'interpeller d'accord
mais répondait à ne jamais passer ça un
vrai débat alors justement ce sera un
autre débat peut-être qu'il faudrait
qu'il faudrait avoir en tout cas merci
de l'avoir eue puisqu'on a auto on a
entendu en tout cas on est d'accord sur
le fait que le point de vue différent
vais être d'accord en tous les cas sur
le fait qu'il ya un vrai débat peut-être
également pour donner plus de visibilité
à la féminisation des noms ce qui est un
autre débat puisque justement c'est le
débat sur le fameux neutre puisque
l'académie française n'était pas
représenté aujourd'hui mais enfin tous
les cas c'est toujours son argument mais
l'orage on l'aura jeu que l'on commande
à un vieil un débat qu'il y avait eu je
me souviens dans le temps notamment sur
sur lci avec quelqu'un un canadien qui
avec un québécois qui avait écrit un
pamphlet contre l'éducation d'acier
contre l'académie française face à
maurice druon et c'était ça valait quand
même le
le détour et là on nous dit il faut
interdire absolument cette écriture
militante pas besoin d'une loi en
revanche estiment mister ce phénomène
ridicule va s'éteindre de lui-même
oui il faut interdire l'écriture
inclusive dans les administrations
estime chris kraus et nicole nous dit
qu'elle a pris le principe de mettre
dans la poubelle tous les emails en
écriture inclusif que elle reçoit donc
éviter au maximum si vous écrivez en
écriture a quitté la cuisine à écrire à
nicole mais vous pourrez venir vous
exprimer sur le plateau de figaro live
ce dont on vous remercie plus qu'une loi
c'est du bon sens qu'il nous faut estime
rico sur youtube et anne estime que
notre langue est déjà suffisamment
compliqué à prendre pour les enfants
pareil pour cet autre internaute qui
nous dit déjà que les enfants ne savent
pas lire en 6e ça promet chardons bleus
tout juste ça juste pour satisfaire des
minorités féministe nicole encore
l'académie française est contre pourquoi
ne suivons nous pas cette position je
crois même que maxime nicole vous a
donné la réponse
enfin tous les cas la sienne cette
écriture intrusive est une sorte de
novlangue je sais pas si les lire avec
vous a écrit à dessein n'est écriture
intrusive
mais c'est ou écriture inclusif si vous
voulez faire un jeu de mots c'est un
lapsus up fax il faut juste l'ignorer
elle disparaîtra tout seul dans quelques
années et sétaient internautes nous dit
encore l'écriture inclusive est
symptomatique de notre époque ça aurait
été intéressant de voir en quoi les
allées selon selon cet internaute comme
si le français n'était pas déjà assez
complexe comme ceux là encore nous dit
chris kraus et lucky sur youtube
les documents administratifs officiels
doivent être rédigées en français
académique la fran langue française
n'est pas assez défendu comparativement
aux autres langues dit francine les
formes de l'écriture inclusive les plus
connus ne respectent pas les lois
grammaticales estime rome
l'état n'a pas compétence pour
réglementer la langue nous dit aveugle
qui est également le pseudonyme d'un
internaute est au fond on est encore
dans les conséquences de mai-68 déplore
christophe cros et pedro enfin je suis
contre l'écriture inclusive en soi mais
l'interdire est une atteinte à la
liberté d'expression alors justement
c'est la question conne qui est posée
sur le site du figaro depuis
et qui va être encore posé jusqu'à
demain vous pouvez continuer à voter si
vous n'avez pas fait faut-il une loi
pour interdire les cris l'écriture
incisive dans les documents
administratifs - y avoir du boulot un
maximum pour convaincre en tout cas les
internautes du figaro puisque eux ils
estiment ils disent oui à 88% donc à la
proposition de françois jolivet merci
ils ont répondu avant le dénommé ainsi
beaucoup
ils ont également pendant le débat merci
merci le pas mal de gens
merci beaucoup de nous avoir nous avoir
oui c'est toujours la loi de say les
minorités dont les victoires les
internautes à mal les minorités
progressiste peut-être dans par les
internautes non salariés merci beaucoup
de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve
demain même heure même endroit à cette
fois ci en respectant les temps parce
que ce sera guillaume roquette qui est
beaucoup plus à cheval que moi sur ces
questions là à très vite sur fear alive
[Musique]